BE A TRAGEDY.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
SPEAKING OF TRAGEDIES, IN THE
EARLY 90s, SOMALIA WAS ROCKED
BY WAR AND FAMINE, THE U.S. SENT
TROOPS NOT TO CONQUER LAND OR
STEEL RESOURCES, BUT TO SAVE
LIVES.
WE DID THAT, SAVED ABOUT 100,000
SOMALIS.
THAT WAS 1993, KNIGHT 1992, I
MISREMEMBERED IT.
SEEMS LIKE JUST YESTERDAY.
SOMALI AMERICAN CONGRESSWOMAN
ILHAN OMAR IS NOT GRATEFUL FOR
WHAT THE U.S. DID ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTRY SHE WAS BORN IN.
AND NO, SHE THINKS AMERICAN
TROOPS ARE THE BAD GUYS IN THAT
CONFLICT THAT A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO SHE RESPONDED ON TWITTER TO
A USER WHO IS OR MIGHT BRING 19
AMERICAN TROOPS KILLED DURING
THE BATTLE, SHE WROTE THIS "IN
HIS SELECTIVE MEMORY, HE FORGETS
TO ALSO MENTION THE THOUSANDS OF
SOMALIS KILLED BY AMERICAN
FORCES THAT DAY!
#NotTodaySatan ."
SERGEANT MAJOR KYLE LAM THOUGHT
THAT DAY IN THE BATTLE, THE
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "LEADERSHIP
IN THE SHADOWS," AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE THEM TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU READ ILHAN
OMAR'S REMARKS ABOUT THE BATTLE
HE FOUGHT IN, WHAT IS YOUR
RESPONSE?
>> NORMALLY IT IS HUMOROUS, BUT
AT THIS POINT, IT IS KIND OF
DISTURBING.
FIRST OF ALL, SHE WASN'T THERE,
SHE HAD ALREADY LEFT THE
COUNTRY.
WE WERE THERE, AND I'VE NEVER
HEARD NUMBERS QUITE THAT
INFLATED.
WE WISH WE COULD HAVE DONE THAT
MUCH DAMAGE, BUT THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN AS FAR AS I KNOW.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS SO STRIKING
IS, AND THE U.S. HAS DONE THINGS
I DISAGREE WITH AROUND THE
WORLD, BUT IN THIS CASE, IT
SEEMS LIKE THE MISSION WAS
PURELY ALTRUISTIC.
WE WERE ONLY THERE TO HELP THERE
WE DIDN'T TAKE SOMALIA.
DID YOU STEAL GOLD OR NATURAL
RESOURCES WHEN YOU WERE THERE?
>> [LAUGHS]
WE DIDN'T DO THAT.
WE ARE TRYING TO TAKE OUT A CLAN
LEADER THAT HAD TAKEN OVER THE
TOWN, THEY WERE TAKING THE FOOD,
ANY OF THE AID WE WERE GIVING TO
SOMALIA, ALSO WEAPONS, RUNNING
DRUGS, A BIG DRUG OVER THERE.
HE NEEDED TO BE ELIMINATED, SO
WE COULD GET PEACE BACK IN THAT
TOWN.
WE WERE ACTUALLY THERE TO HELP
SOME OF THE LESSER TRIBES, THE
LESSER CLANS, SUCH AS HER CLAN,
WHICH OBVIOUSLY THEY WERE
ALREADY GONE.
BUT WE WERE THERE TO TRY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
THE OTHER THING IS, WE DIDN'T
SAY "HEY, LET'S PICK OUT SOMALIA
IS A GREAT PLACE TO GO HANG
OUT."
THE PRESIDENT OF THE TIME,
PRESIDENT CLINTON, SAID THIS IS
WHERE WE ARE GOING, THIS IS THE
MISSION, AND OUR COMMANDER SAID
"ROGER THAT, WE CAN DO IT," AND
WILL SIGN ON THE LINE.
THAT IS WHY WE SERVED.
YOU CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
YOU GO TO THOSE COUNTRIES.
>> Tucker: DOES IT STRIKE YOU
AS ODD, I DON'T WANT TO PICK ON
ILHAN OMAR, BUT SHE IS A MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, AND SO HER
STATEMENTS GET A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
HERE'S SOMEONE WHO WAS BROUGHT
TO THE UNITED STATES AT PUBLIC
EXPENSE SIMPLY BECAUSE WE ARE A
KIND COUNTRY THAT ACCEPTS A LOT
OF REFUGEES, AND RATHER THAN
BEING GRATEFUL FOR THAT, SHE
SPENT THE REST OF HER LIFE
ATTACKING THIS COUNTRY.
WHY?
>> AS THEY WOULD SAY DOWN HERE
IN TENNESSEE, BLESS HER HEART.
WE WANT HER TO UNDERSTAND THAT
SHE IS LIVING LARGE NOW BECAUSE
OF HER FAMILY BEING ABLE TO
ESCAPE THE ATROCITIES OF
MOGADISHU.
IT IS DISTURBING, WE WATCH OUR
FRIENDS GET DRUG THROUGH THE
STREETS BY THE PEOPLE SHE SAYS
ARE HER PEOPLE.
WE GOT TO WATCH THAT ON TV, ONCE
WE GOT FROM THE CRASH SITE I WAS
OUT AND GOT BACK TO OUR HANGER,
THAT IS WHAT WE GOT TO WATCH.
YEAH, WE TAKE IT PERSONAL WHEN
YOU ATTACK US LIKE THAT.
ONCE AGAIN, IT IS NOT SURPRISING
TO HEAR THAT.
THERE HAS BEEN KIND OF A LONG
LIST OF THINGS SHE SAID, I DON'T
KNOW IF SHE MEANT THEM OR NOT,
BUT SHE CONTINUES TO SAY THEM.
YEAH, I FEEL BAD FOR HER.
>> Tucker: YEAH, I DO TOO.
WHAT ABOUT THE FAMILIES OF
AMERICANS WHO WERE KILLED THERE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY THINK OF
THIS?
>> I HAVEN'T TALKED TO ANY OF
THE FAMILIES, BUT IT DOESN'T
TAKE HER SAYING SOMETHING TO
REMIND THEM OF WHAT THEY DEAL
WITH EVERY DAY.
WHENEVER THEY GO TO A BASEBALL
GAME AND THEY HEAR THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM, THEY LOOK AT
THE FLAG, THAT DAD IS NOT THERE
WITH HIS KIDS.
THAT'S A STORY, NOT JUST FROM
SOMALIA, BUT ALL THE OTHER
CONFLICTS I HAVE BEEN IN, AND
THAT I HAVEN'T BEEN IN, THAT IS
THE STORY OF A SOLDIER.
THAT IS WHAT WE DEAL WITH ON A
DAILY BASIS.
AND REALLY, WE JUST WANT PEOPLE
TO HELP US OUT WHEN WE GET BACK,
WHICH REASON WE NEED A MISSION,
GUYS TO GET HELP IF THEY HAVE
DRUG OR ALCOHOL ISSUES, WHICH
SOMETIMES CAN BE PREVALENT IN
THE MILITARY IF GUYS ARE
SUFFERING WITH INJURIES THAT
THEY TRY TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
WITH.
WE TRY TO GET THEM THE HELP WE
CAN, THAT IS WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
YEAH, IT IS THE SOLDIER'S STORY
FROM THE LAST 10,000 YEARS.
>> Tucker: THE LAST THING YOU